[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 8 septembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 78 le journal on
commence tout de suite avec votre
sommaire nouvelle résidence étudiante
dans la commune de Laverrière elle a
ouvert à la fin de l'été et peut
accueillir plus de 180 personnes nous
l'avons visité une nouvelle église
devrait voir le jour à voisin le
Bretonneux attendu depuis 10 ans elle
devrait sortir de terre en 2019 les
précisions à suivre et enfin il faudra
attendre janvier 2017 mais la DLE des 7
mars sera bien rénové ces travaux
s'inscrivent dans un projet de
reconstruction globale plus large les
explications dans cette édition et on
ouvre le journal avec cette information
une fausse alerte attentat à morpa un
véhicule suspect a été identifié ce
jeudi 8 septembre vers midi par les
autorités il stationnait sur une zone
interdite devant le collège Louis PERG
le quartier a été encerclé par une
vingtaine de policiers les riverins ont
été évacués les élèves du collège et les
enfants de l'école citcante ont été
confinés dans leur locaux un des mineurs
est intervenu au final rien n'a signalé
le véhicule lui a été envoyé à la
fourrière je vous propose d'écouter à
présent le maire de morpa Grégory garest
garestier pardon il était au micro de
Nicolas
dandr la partie confinement pour le
collège c'est bien déroulé la partie
confinement pour l'école cité centre
c'est également bien déroulé il y a un
courrier à maignature qui là va être
distribué à tous les parents d'élèves de
l'école cité centre l'école maternelle
et également un autre courrier à la
signature de la principale du collège
Pergo et de la mienne pour voilà
rassurer les parents d'élèves sur ce qui
s'est passé mais aussi c'est une épreuve
qui a choqué beaucoup d'enfants et donc
il va y avoir également une une cellule
psychologique qui va être mis en place
pour justement euh être auprès des
enfants et à présent un mot sur la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
collèges dans l'académie de Versailles
c'est 4,8 % des enseignants qui étaient
en grève aujourd'hui un taux 1ès en de
ça de la mobilisation des mois derniers
les enseignants répondaient à l'appel
une semaine après la rentrée de
l'intersyndicale du second degré alors
selon les chiffres communiqués par le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale 4,6 %
des enseignants des collèges publics et
un ,1 % des enseignants des lycées
étaient étaient gréistes aujourd'hui
alors l'intersyndical constitué du SNES
eessu qui est le premier syndicat du
secondaire du SNEP FSU FO CGT SUD et
saindep a appelé à manifester à Paris au
départ de la place de la Sorbonne
Delphine Romanie secrétaire SNES FSU
desvin y était je vous propose de
l'écouter nous l'avons joint par
téléphone c'est une mobilisation c'est
sûr on va pas se cacher qui est pas
énorme c'est une mobilisation de rentrée
donc les collègues sont aussi dans leur
rentrée leur emploi du temps la mise en
place de leur de leur vie personnelle
donc c'est compliqué pour se mobiliser
moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
sur l'académie de Versailles c'est le
point de départ de la mobilisation de
rentrée donc nous on va mener des
actions tout au long du mois de
septembre des assemblées général avec
les collègues des réunions à destination
des parents d'élèves un stage qui sera à
destination des enseignants qui sera de
la formation syndicale sur la réforme du
collège donc voilà tout ça bien sûr
parce que nous notre mod d'ordre
aujourd'hui c'était l'abrogation de la
réforme du collège
tout autre sujet à présent Saint-Quentin
envine peut désormais accueillir plus
d'étudiants des nouveaux logements qui
leur sont destinés sont sortis de terre
cétait cet été à la verrière la
résidence vient d'ouvrir ses portes
juste à côté de la gare 1619 chambres
ont déjà trouvé preneur les précisions
avec Nicolas
kirilovitz de 300 à 450 € pour une
taille moyenne de 19 m car un prix et
une taille attractif voilà l'offre de la
nouvelle résidence étudiante situé à La
Verrière à une centaine de mètres de la
gare SNCF ouvert depuis la fin août les
179 studios sont déjà tous occupés au
début ça a commencé très bien parce
qu'on a eu beaucoup de demandes on est
déjà complet
et la demande ça se fait par internet
donc on a une grande liste de d'attentes
et je pense par rapport au prix c'est
c'est une avantage parce que vous avez
de
300 € à 450 € Elsa 17 ans originaire de
Normandie s'est installée il y a
quelques jours dans sa chambre vivre en
résidence c'est également pour elle
l'occasion de rencontrer d'autres
étudiants et d'éviter le blues de la
rentrée c'est pas mal parce que bah le
loyer est pas très cher et tout est
compris à part l'électricité donc enfin
il y a même internet donc c'est assez
pratique pour faire des recherches des
trucs comme ça et puis plus c'est bien
parce que je suis pas toute seule parce
que là je me retrouve un peu isolé donc
comme ça je peux je peux rencontrer des
gens de ma résidence enfin y a que des
étudiants donc c'est sympa de salalles
communes une laverie un parking un
garage à vélo la nouvelle résidence
étudiante de la verrière dispose de
nombreux services plus aucun logement
n'est disponible pour cette année
scolaire et on continue avec des travaux
mais cette fois-ci du côté d'encour
elles sont considérées comme dangereuses
les dalles des 7 mars seront bientôt
supprimées à H encour un chantier de
rénovation devait débuté en juin il a
finalement été reporté à janvier 2017 un
projet qui répond au aux nombreuses
demandes des habitants et à la création
d'une école de musique dans ce quartier
les précisions avec Camille Lambert
dangereus usée les dalles des setmar ne
seront bientôt plus qu'un souvenir à
hencour avec la création d'une école de
musique à la place de l'ancien centre
cuménique la mairie et Saint-Quentin en
iveline ont souhaité rajeunir le
centreville les commerçants se
plaignaient effectivement de de de de
problème d'éclairage se plaignit aussi
de l'état de la dalle qui faisait qu'il
y avait un certain nombre de personnes
qui avaient été accidenté en tombant
nous avions nous-même un certain nombre
de courriers que nous avions reçu en ce
sens pour nous il y avait une volonté de
leur donner la possibilité de
redynamiser l'aspect économique de cette
de cette dalle début du chantier janvier
2017 les pavés seront remplacés par un
enrobé de bitume rouge décoré par des
notes de musique un éclairage nocturne
viendra compléter cette création en
faisant apparaître des gammes sur le sol
un moyen d'améliorer la sécurité et
l'hygiène de les pass je suis déjà tombé
une fois j'ai un sou dev la boulangerie
parce qu'il y a un petit décalage au
moins 4 5 cm et j'étais en fauteil
manuelle et par j'ai poussé un peu trop
vite et j'ai basculé parce que ça fait
sales et que cé un peu insaluble au
niveau de d'en dessous puisque ça c'est
pas stable et qu'il y a de l'eau donc à
un moment où ça dépend de la température
ça sent pas bon un nouveau système de
sécurité avec des alarmes sera aussi
mise en place pour les commerçants coût
des travaux pour la dalle plus de 2 mil
d'EUR le projet devrait être terminé
pour fin
2017 et toujours à encour le foyer des
travailleurs Adoma va être reconstruit
les logements jugés très véustes ne
répondent plus aux normes de sécurité et
d'accessibilité du public alors
plusieurs incendies se sont déjà
déclencher dans ce bâtiment dont le
dernier au mois de juillet 2016 la
future résidence sociale devrait
proposer 190 chambres les précisions
avec Camille
Lambert le foyer Adoma d'élancour va
faire pet neuve des travaux attendus
depuis longtemps pour ce bâtiment mis en
service dans les années 70
l'établissement jugé précaire ne répond
plus aux normes de sécurité et
d'accessibilité du public preuve de sa
véuseté un incendie déclaré en juillet
au 3e étage quatre personnes ont été
blessées vous avez uniquement euh une de
quoi dormir euh les douches communes les
WC à l'étage commun euh la même chose
pour pour faire sa cuisine à partir du
moment vous avez des bâtiments qui sont
véus les conditions de vie sont sont
incorrectes le comportement devient
correct aussi le bâtiment actuel sera
démoli pour laisser place à une
résidence sociale 190 logements sont
prévus au sein de ce nouvel équipement
au lieu de 280 aujourd'hui une
construction à taille humaine avec des
studios de 16 m car minimum tout équipé
là vous aurez vraiment des petits T1
avec tout le confort nécessaire
aussi bien au niveau sanitaire toilettes
que kitchinette ce qui donnera des
conditions de vie totalement différentes
un mode de fonctionnement totalement
différent et qui sera plus en adéquation
avec ce qu'on est droit d'attendre quand
on on est logé quelque part financé par
Adoma avec l'aide de l'État le chantier
devrait débuter en janvier 2017 le
nouveau bâtiment sera construit sur la
zone verte actuelle pour loger les
habitants avant de détruire l'ancien le
déménagement des résidents est prévu
pour
2018 et religion à présent c'est la
dernière ligne droite pour le temple des
Mormons du chînet débé débuté pardon en
2013 les travaux touchent à leur fin le
temple pourra accueillir jusqu'à s
adeptes l'église Mormon Église de
Jésus-Christ des Saints des Derniers
Jours est une religion chrétienne qui
est née aux États-Unis en 1830
l'inauguration est attendue pour le
prier semestre de l'année 2017 écouter
le porte-parole de l'église Mormon au
micro de Camille lombert on peut penser
qu'il va y avoir des personnalités on
invite d'abord tout le monde toutes les
personnalités françaises à venir à à ses
portes ouvertes euh politiqu mais pas
simplement politique dans tous les
domaines de la société les fidèles sont
très impatients d'avoir ce nouveau
temple puisque ce temple va leur éviter
de faire des milliers de kilomètres hein
les les Parisiens vont soit à Londres
soit à Francfort soit à Bern en Suisse
donc ils font 1200 km à l'erretour donc
ils sont impatients de pouvoir ne plus
les faire et religion toujours les
fidèles attendent sa construction depuis
plus de 10 ans la nouvelle église de
voisin le Bretonneux devrait sortir de
terre pour Noël 2019 ce nouveau lieu de
culte de 2000 m car pourra accueillir
jusqu'à 800 fidèles actuellement la
capacité des établissements de voisins
et de monten le bretonis n'excède pas
les 200 places les détails de ce projet
avec am
Lambert chaque dimanche les 100
paroissiens de voisin le bretonne sont
peu pour assister aux messes lancée par
le diocèse de Versailles la construction
d'une nouvelle église dans la ville
devrait débuter prochainement elle
deviendra la plus grande église de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
nuveline on a la chance d'avoir une
communauté paroissiale très dynamique
mais aujourd'hui on est éclaté sur sur
trois lieux et tous les moments forts de
l'année comme pâqu comme Noël comme les
premières communions les confirmations
bah c'est des moments qu'on doit vivre
séparé en fait il manque une église une
église qui soit moderne à la taille et à
l'image de la ville nouvelle attendu
depuis 10 ans le projet devrait sortir
de terre dans la future zone
d'aménagement concertée de la remise
l'église Saint-Joseph le bienveillant
pourra accueillir jusqu'à 800
paroissiens l'architecture a été confiée
à un cabinet de Rome le Centro aléti
c'est un cabinet qui rassemble toutes
sortes de corps de métier des des
architectes bien sûr mais aussi des
sculpteurs des peintres des mosaïstes
pour porter de manière intégrale les
projets d'art sacré c'est un cabinet qui
a fait des mosaïques par par exemple à
lourde ou ailleurs et c'est la première
fois que la France fait appel à lui pour
construire une église donc c'est un
projet assez innovant coup des opération
7 millions d'euros entièrement financé
par le diocèse de Versailles plusieurs
réunions publiques devraient être
organisées durant l'automne pour
présenter les premières esquisses du
bâtiment si tout avance comme prévu les
fidèles pourront fêter Noël 2019 dans
leur nouvelle
église et pour finir à ce journal un mot
de sport le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin en ivine va accueillir à
partir de ce jeudi 8 septembre la
première édition du Paris Legend
Championship plus de 52 champions et
anciens vainqueur de tournoi majeur
seront présents pour ce rendez-vous le
public pourra voir le fantasque
américain John Day qui sera de la partie
il affrontera l'Espagnol Joan Kiros et
l'Anglais David Russell l'organisateur
Alexis Sikorski nous présente cette
compétition déjà légendaire selon lui
c'est une première édition pour la
France il s'agit du our européens senior
c'està-dire les joueurs qui ont plus de
50 ans les légendes qui ont donné 30 ans
de leur vie à notre sport les gens avec
lesquels on a grandi qu'on a vu sur le
parcours depuis des années c'est une
compétition officielle 52 joueurs
pendant 3 jours vendredi samedi dimanche
Alexis Sikorski au micro de Michel
elmidoro c'est la fin de cette émission
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivi je
vous retrouve lundi pour une nouvelle
édition du JT je vous souhaite donc une
très bonne soirée et un excellent
[Musique]
weekend